[Music]
de novo sequencing in assembly is
typically applied to organisms where no
reference genome is available or the
available reference is of poor quality
genomes that have not been sequenced
before must be assembled via a de novo
approach
following sequencing this assembly can
then be used for additional analyses
and the basis for future resequencing
projects
resequencing is typically performed when
a reference genome
sequence is available sequencing reads
are aligned back to the reference to
determine the location in the genome the
specific red best matches
resequencing is often applied to explore
genetic variation in
individuals families and populations
particularly with respect to human
genetic disease
requirements for sequencing depth in
these studies are governed by the
variant type of interest
the disease model and the size of the
regions of interest
resequencing can reveal single
nucleotide polymorphisms
small insertions or deletions structural
variants
and copy number variation naturally
the design of a particular study depends
on the biological hypothesis in question
and different sequencing strategies are
used for population studies compared
with those for studies of mendelian
disease or of somatic mutations in
cancer
furthermore targeted resequencing
approaches allow a trade-off between
sequencing breadth and sample numbers
for the same cost more samples can be
sequenced to the same depth
but over a smaller genomic region here
we discuss the merits of whole genome
sequencing
or wgs relative to targeted
re-sequencing approaches
including whole exam sequencing in the
context of these different variant types
and disease models
high depth wgs is the gold standard for
dna resequencing because it can
interrogate all variant types including
snvs
indoles structural variants and cnvs in
both the minority of the human genome
that encodes proteins and the remaining
majority of non-coding sequences
whole exam sequencing is focused on the
detection of snvs and indoles in protein
coding genes and on other functional
elements such as micro rna sequences
consequently it omits regulatory regions
such as promoters and enhancers
although costs vary depending on the
sequence capture solution
whole exam sequencing can be an order of
magnitude less expensive than wgs to
achieve an approximately equivalent
breadth of coverage of protein coding
exons
these reduced costs offer the potential
to greatly increase sample numbers
which is a key factor for many studies
however
whole exam sequencing has various
limitations that are discussed below
early genome resequencing studies
focused specifically on the two most
common classes of sequence variation
which are snvs and small indoles the
first human genome that was sequenced
using illumina short read technology
showed that although almost
all homozygous snvs are detected at a 15
times average depth
an average depth of 33 times is required
to detect the same proportion of
heterozygous snvs
consequently an average depth that
exceeds 30 times rapidly became the de
facto standard
although read quality is mostly governed
by sequencing technology
the uniformity of depth of coverage can
also be affected by sample preparation
a gc bias that is introduced during dna
amplification by pcr
has been identified as a major source of
variation in coverage
elimination of pcr amplification results
in improved coverage of high gc regions
of the genome
and in fewer duplicate reads in whole
exam sequencing
differences in the hybridization
efficiency of sequence capture probes
which are possibly again attributable to
gc content variation
can result in target regions that have
little or no coverage
uniformity of coverage will also be
influenced by repetitive or low
complexity sequences which either
restrict bait design or lead to
off-target capture
furthermore unlike wgs west still
routinely uses pcr
amplification which must be carefully
optimized to reduce gc bias
as a result of increased variation in
coverage a greater average read depth
is required to achieve the same breadth
of coverage as that from wgs
and an 80 times average depth is
required to cover 89.6 to 96.8
percent of target bases all whole exam
sequencing kits are prone to reference
bias
which arises from capture probes that
match the reference sequence
and thus tend to preferentially enrich
the reference allele at heterozygous
sites
such bias can produce false negative snv
calls
cnvs can be detected from wgs and whole
exam sequencing data using methods that
analyze depth of coverage
these methods pile up aligned reads
against genomic coordinates
then calculate read counts in windows to
provide the average depth across a
region
copy number changes can then be inferred
from variation in average depth across
genomic regions
in wgs reasonable specificity can be
obtained with an average depth of as
little as 0.1 times
however sensitivity breakpoint detection
and absolute copy number estimation
all improve with increasing red depth
regardless of average read depth
depth of coverage methods are vulnerable
to false positives that are being called
owing to local variations in coverage
even after correction for both gc bias
and map ability and cross sample calling
is required to reduce this effect
in contrast to the high depth sequencing
that is required to accurately call
snvs and indoles in individual genomes
population genomic studies benefit from
a trade-off between sample numbers and
sequencing depth
in which many genomes are sequenced at
low depth for example
400 samples at four times and their
variants are called jointly across
all samples variant calls on individual
low depth genomes have a high false
positive rate
but this is mitigated by combining
information across samples
this approach provides good power to
detect common variants
at a proportion of the sequencing cost
of deep sequencing
indeed even ultra low coverage
sequencing that is
sequencing its 0.1 to 0.5 times
captures almost as much common variation
as single nucleotide polymorphism arrays
conversely reliable identification of
variants in either highly aneuploid
genomes or heterogeneous cell
populations
such as those from tumors requires
greater depth of coverage than those
from normal tissue
targeted enrichment and ultra deep
sequencing such as sequencing at one
zero zero zero times of limited regions
of interest can be used to study clonal
evolution in cancer samples
in which specific variants are present
in less than one percent of the cell
population
the identification of disease-causing de
novo or recessive variants is often best
served by sequencing parent
child trios in this case it is
recommended that the same depth of
sequencing
is obtained for each of the family
members in order to minimize false
positive calls in the pro band and false
negative calls in the parents
[Music]